when we get pulled over in the back cars
uh
luckily a lot of the police officers
just want their picture taken with it
yes sir you can please do
we've created the bat car from the
michael keaton batman movie the mystery
machine from scooby-doo
everything from herbie the love bug to
the land speeder from star wars
we create a lot of wild rides out of
some junk
in the past two or three years we've
created uh 15 16 iconic movie cars
i had a real job at one time in a major
airline
we initially started out refurbishing
old cars we decided we were going to
start making some iconic cars that you
could actually get in and out of it
drive it kids can climb on it and look
at it
typical builds can be anywhere from
as little as two weeks to as much as
three years
the speed racer mach 5 sitting here
beside us started off as a 94 corvette
hopefully here in about 30 days it'll be
finished up have a great big honking m
on the hood of it it'll look awesome
there's a tremendous amount of trial and
error a lot of these cars have a lot of
fiberglass on them
it's a labor of love to come out and
just continue putting down layers and
layers of fiberglass
you can't go to o'reilly's or advanced
auto parts and ask them for a part for a
back car
our eleanor from ghana 60 seconds car up
front is absolutely as screen accurate
as we can get it from the
stainless aluminum interior to the seats
to the shifter the go baby switch in the
center and we drive eleanor just like
it's supposed to be driven that's why it
was
built everything we have we take out and
drive every single piece we take it all
to the local stores we go to mcdonald's
what better thing to get groceries in
the back car
you